allison is a huge animal rights activist
and i am a dog lover of i don't know
almost 30 years
and one of our dilemmas that allison and
i were speaking of is when you have
dogs cats pets in your home
and you love design it's a little hard
to blend the two together
and um alison i would like to introduce
you to the man
who made this oasis possible and who's
going to show us
how pets and design can come
together it is the very talented
interior designer powerhouse nate
so burquez and you two know each other
from the help because you produced it
nate with allison i did hi allison how
are you
hi nate it's great to see you oh look at
those
pictures of my face i mean this looks
incredible
thanks i'm freaking out how did you do
this walk us through it
and teach us how to bring design and our
love
of our family members our pets together
yeah all right so the first thing is
actually
when you have pets and you have a ton of
stuff visual
organization is the most important thing
so if you look around the space
um for allison obviously these three
cute faces
they're all images are all framed the
same the signs are all in the same exact
font the bowls are not on the floor
they're mounted
which just keeps the floor like you know
it makes little cuddly places for them
to go underneath
but one of the principles in design no
matter who you're designing for is
think about furniture in unexpected ways
so
this is a dining room sideboard i
removed a lot of the interior shelves so
basically this is like dog central
um leashes go in baskets oh my gosh
go in containers everything you need
extra blankets those weird blankets that
they always like
you know scramble on and leave all over
the place all of that stuff can go
behind closed doors and then when you
add lamps to it you have the lighting
coming through from your kitchen side
as well as from um the from from the dog
side because the dogs should have a nice
place to be too right
absolutely i have to say i would have
never thought
to use a different piece of furniture
for
dog storage and also you've got wood
here
but you've got wood here then you've got
wood in the frames
and all of this wood that element really
speaks to each other and there's a
really beautiful cohesion going on here
well definitely and that's the visual
clutter aspect because you know all
three dog beds match
an outdoor rug makes the room softer so
you know i think that that's the
counterbalance and that's the magic of
design when
you take something and make it feel
really sophisticated but its purpose
is just fun alison what do you think of
this
and would you have ever thought to use
a different type of furniture for the
dogs
i i'm just i'm just floored i'm loving
everything about this i love the i
love that uh piece of furniture i love
repurposing it for the dog area it's
absolutely stunning i love those lamps
and i love the rug
and the beds are stunning they're so
gorgeous i've never had
three uh uh beds the same you know
they're all
just a mishmash in my house so those are
just gorgeous i'm gonna
curl up in one of those i i i
also the um the food bowls that that's
that's such a cool idea i love that um
idea and also because i think it's
better for the dogs to eat without
having to benefit you know it's good for
them to have the food more
you know at their mouth level i know
it's actually a very quite comfortable
little spot here i know
i that's why i was like yeah here you
have this one
okay and then this is just yeah we're
clean allison you don't have to do
anything with these with me
when they arrive in california um
allison we just want to thank you so
much
for inspiring us um you know nate and i
to tackle um your beautiful
doggy um dilemma and we all have it as
pet
owners yeah and we're not all lucky
enough to have a nate burkus
come in and tell us how to do it and yet
now we can all
learn from this example and i'm
so inspired and thank you nate of course
you think it's gonna be weird for alice
and jenny when she comes home and we're
like in the dog bed still no oh that's
the other thing allison nate and i are
coming with all this stuff
here finally yes you're coming over
we're going to make this happen drew
totally alison you are the greatest this
has been one of the funnest things i've
ever gotten to do here
thank you so much thank you nate to be
continued we're going to do the news
together yeah yeah
okay great all right nate thank you i
really i'm so excited
about this i really am and drew i love
you so much thank you for
for creating this for me i'm really i
just
i'm very excited to up up to upgrade my
dog
look how excited dutch is he's thrilled
i appreciate his enthusiasm for my
design
listen happy client you know i mean i
just keep winning
yeah exactly what you don't want is the
client in your face disagreeing with
everything you
alison thank you so much and thank you
for everything you put out into the
world and
be sure to catch alice and jenny in our
final season of mom
thursday nights on cbs
you